so the chatter in the ufc world did you
guys see francis ingano's
yeah we need to talk about it this is
this isn't ghana's tweet it's crazy to
think that logan paul
zero and one just made 20 million
dollars on a boxing exhibition
what are we doing wrong in caps hmm
and he was in the audience by the way
paul acosta said he's not fighting
paul acosta is that guy the big juice up
guy that easy took out i think he said
he's not fighting until they work on
like fighter pay
yeah um in the ufc so it is kind of
interesting the ripple effect of what
the paul brown
breaking mma it's fascinating to watch
and jake is the guy that started it dana
white has got to be like what the
[ __ ] technically it's located
yeah yeah i meant jake was the one that
went at ufc fighters and he started
going specifically like
why are you getting paid so he's
trolling this movement this weekend in
miami was the bitcoin conference and he
did a panel with like tim dillon and
boss twins and he's and he was calling
dana white a [ __ ]
at a huge conference for bitcoin and
it's just like this is what we're doing
these
these fighters get paid enough i need to
hear the argument from
i didn't hear the argument from dana
because yes they're taking
way more money from these fights right
but
they have way more overhead right like
the ufc has like
actual phys uh physical facilities that
they have to maintain
they uh are their own promoter
there are way more costs that they have
their overhead is way higher the
promoting of all these fighters etc
so i'd like to see what their takeaway
is after
you calculate in the pr that they're
constantly pumping out for all their
fighters they are the promoter
for every fighter on the roster in
boxing that is not the case
the wbc does not promote whoever is
fighting
for the heavyweight tyson fury tyson
fury promotes size and fury
so if that's what you want to do if you
want to do mma where you're your own
promoter
that's fine i know a lot of those
fighters in mma right now that do not
want to do that
right i know a lot of those guys just
want to be gym rats hang out there
let uh let's go dana white and the ufc
build the folklore around them
and then go out and fight and they'll
take less money because they don't have
to do it i mean put it this way
if you don't speak english you're [ __ ]
if you don't speak english
there's no chance that you have of
winning over an american
audience without a promotional
enterprise like the ufc helping you out
mm-hmm
so of course it's gonna be didn't have
connor how much would we give a [ __ ]
it's a great point do any of the ufc
fighters besides like
obviously conor like get at least a tiny
percentage of numbers so you're always
at least hedging against you mean like
of a pay-per-view mm-hmm i think they do
probably the elite elite yeah but is
there a way to give that to across the
board to anyone that's on some of the
main fights
even a percent even just they know look
there's ways there's ways i guess what
i'm trying to say is like i need to know
the numbers from the ufc side before i
i call them these like money grubbing
pigs
right because they might just have way
more overhead than these
than fan meow or whatever it is because
fan meow doesn't need to promote the
fight
it's easy for the paul brothers who have
these like robust social media channels
to say hey you should be paid more they
should be paid more because they're
doing the pr
yeah but if you don't have that who
should be paid more
right but still even in regular boxing
real fights
the purse is a lot bigger so i think
that i think that goes down
i think that goes down because i don't
think regular fights are generating the
income
that they used to i think it's one of
those things like it's almost like
baseball where it's like this legacy
sport and the guys are already making so
much yeah
and then eventually you're like these tv
deals are going to go down because
nobody's watching baseball yeah and once
those tv deals go down those
those huge salaries they're gonna start
tanking as well
i think the same thing will start
happening with boxing yeah and let's be
serious with boxing
most boxers are making absolutely
nothing we're talking about just the
cream of the crop yeah
that's what yeah your point still stands
about overhead but one of the reasons
boxing viewership is down is because ufc
is taking it yeah they're dominating
market share so even if overheads are
they dominate market share because their
pr
is better they're selling their fighters
better they got fighters that have 10
losses that we still watch that doesn't
exist in boxing
think about it like you can be a ufc
fighter this is your job security you
can be a ufc fighter as long as you're
assigned to the ufc
we'll probably watch you if you're a
boxer and you have 10 losses
we're asking you to retire we're going
hey it's over for you
you don't have a shot they're a legacy
ufc guy cowboy cerrone
if he wants can still fight yeah i'll
watch it we'll still watch it
the guy hasn't won i think in like five
years or something like that
it's unbelievable so once you're part of
there's value to that machine
how much of your salary is that worth
how much of your salary is it worth you
not having to win every single time you
go out and still get paid the next time
the same amount in boxing you get paid
the millions as long as you're winning
the second you
you might be down to a tenth of your
salary right in the ufc you make the
same
every single time with potential upset
uh upside
if you're maybe doing a pay-per-view or
something like that all i'm saying is
there might be an argument from their
side
would i like them to get more yes i want
fighters to make all the [ __ ] money
but i need to know the true numbers for
the ufc
before i say that they're just raping
all the fighters is that fair
yeah but one thing that makes you
skeptical of rip is they have
shareholders
and if you got shareholders that's the
number one person you're trying to
please
so you're going to try to keep profits
as high as possible to keep your stock
price as high as possible so that's
where i'm a little skeptical
also i was wondering about ufc just now
is it popular because why don't you
don't have profits
what do you mean actually the motto now
is you don't need profits
you don't need a profitable business you
keep your your yeah
you really just need the share price to
be high how is the share price high
is people are talking about your company
and people believe that it will grow
yeah so in a weird way they don't even
need a profit they can take all the
money dump it right back in the business
as long as wme stock goes up and wme
owns the ufc
everybody's [ __ ] happy right is it
crazy that's valid
what world do we live in right now where
your business doesn't need
to be profitable you just got to believe
in a long term
[ __ ] me
you